let's move on now and talk about a rhode
island state senator named tiara mack
she's gone viral on social media for her
let's just say unique approach to voter
outreach this is the video here and it's
gone viral for all the wrong reasons if
you're asking some people take a look at
how she's encouraging people to get out
the vote
[Music]
vote senator mack
okay well she posted that video on july
4th she is a self-described queer
reproductive rights activist who also
supports the green new deal and gun
control but you probably already knew
that
the idea of that video to get attention
and it's working i guess right of course
she supports rhode island's creepy sex
education bill for public schools as
well here's what she tweeted back in
february about it really excited for the
house sex ed bill hearing today teaching
comprehensive queer inclusive
pleasure-based sex ed was a highlight of
my time teaching
and if you read the bill it's as bad as
it sounds let's talk about this now with
the host of the reuben report dave rubin
his book is doing very well right now
don't burn this country and if you're
lucky and down in miami you can catch
them at a special show on july 14th dave
great to have you back with us
john it's good to be with you uh real
quick i reached out to sir mix-a-lot
about this video that we just saw there
and he said and i quote
i like big butts and i cannot lie that's
what i was told by sir mix a lot related
to this i don't know if you want me to
comment on it as well but i thought that
stands on its own well i think if you
read the comments uh below her video
that she posted i mean she's now saying
oh well look i i really you know raged
the right because i posted a video
myself twerking and it's not it's not
the twerking part that has that happens
all the time on the internet this is an
elected official a state senator someone
who's supposed to be a quote unquote
leader um a role model for our kids at
least that was the idea once upon a time
with elected officials but what do you
call this
well i'm actually all for this stuff now
i've really had a shift and it's a
mindset shift that i would welcome you
to join me on john
which is that the more that these
lefties show you who they are that this
upside down twerking beach woman who's a
genderqueer unicorn or whatever she is
the more that they show you who they are
let's let them show us who they are
let's encourage them to keep showing us
who they are how they are deeply
unserious people how they are not
equipped to deal with any of the
problems of the day and that perhaps
there are some other people out there
who maybe don't have as big butts and
maybe cannot balance on their heads but
maybe can try to solve some of the
problems that we americans face so
that's kind of where i'm at at the
moment and you might just be saying well
dave that's because you got a bum
shoulder and you can't get upside down
anymore and that's partly true but not
totally true there are videos of dave
rubin twerking on the internet i'm
kidding of course um but you know the
her defenders i think they were also you
know they were criticizing people who
thought this wasn't right for well she's
honored it's july 4th it's her day off i
mean how dare you um david cecilia he's
a
democratic congressman uh you know his
chief of staff said look
i'm shirtless and smoking weed all the
time nobody you know criticizes me for
doing that and like you're a chief of
staff she's an elected official
you know it's not because she's
genderqueer or because she's twerking
it's because she's a state senator in
doing those things like that and pushing
it on kids
that's that's the thing anyone can smoke
weed if you want to smoke weed you can
twerk if you want to torque but we have
to decide are these the people that we
want being in charge of policy if you
are watching that video of her and
you're going boy i really do want to
vote for her she seems like she's got
her head on straight i mean her head's
upside down but her head's not straight
she's going to solve she's look at this
look at this i mean my god is that a
problem solver or what i mean right
yeah you know okay so the choice the
choice is clear so again i think we
should just encourage them to be who
they are be who you are people fly that
freak flag and let's see what happens
you know my grandmother was very wise
she told me never to vote for anyone who
has their head in the sand either that
was a reference to a different kind of
bird but whatever we'll move on um all
right let's follow up too on some hunter
biden laptop news i i want to pay very
close attention to white house press
secretary karine jean-pierre and how she
answered this question about hunter
biden's laptop take a look what i can
tell you from here standing at this
podium is that i cannot comment
on any materials from the laptop and i
would refer you to the representatives
of of hunter biden that's what i can
share with you at this podium at this
time
okay she says she cannot share any more
information but i wonder dave if this
has anything to do
with the federal investigation into
hunter biden's laptop oftentimes you
know your hands are tied
uh when a federal investigation is going
on you know either she doesn't want to
tell us she can't tell us which one is
it
well she's a liar i mean she is hired to
lie for the administration and because
the entire administration is based in
lies virtually everything they say is a
lie then she just has to continue lying
it's interesting because as you know
from that extended portion of that clip
she's responding to a question by peter
ducey where he's talking about a phone
call
he's not talking about exactly what's on
the laptop it's a phone a voicemail that
joe biden left for hunter biden i don't
know why she can't comment on that by
the way the the laptop was never hacked
into it was voluntarily given to this
computer repair shop guy you know we
couldn't talk about that two years ago
now new york times is willing to admit
it's true so we're allowed to talk about
it again but i think they are really in
deep and you know if you listen further
to what she said there's sort of this
feeling i think that's going to get
stronger and stronger that the machine
or the democrat machine whatever you
want to call it it's sort of almost done
with biden what it had to do was defeat
trump and they felt that he was the best
thing to at least defeat trump but it's
almost done with him his slurring and
the cognitive stuff and the disastrous
economy and the ukraine stuff and
blaming everything on putin all the time
it's not working anymore so they're
getting ready to figure out who's going
to take over in 2024 because it ain't
going to be joe biden despite the fact
that kamala harris said that he's gonna
run although if you saw that clip john
she was saying he's gonna run he's gonna
run and i have to say this so i don't
get in trouble with the federal
elections commission but whatever you
know yes everything is conditional uh
because the law says so not because it's
what's in their mind
all right dave i feel like all the cool
kids are getting suspended from twitter
which you're in that category now after
you
just took a screenshot of a jordan
peterson tweet about elliott page uh and
when you read the stories about this and
they even write stories about you
getting canceled by twitter that's how
cool you are um this this term dead
naming gets dropped into the copy like
we're all supposed to know what this
stuff is i heard about this word for the
first time two weeks ago this is when
you use a transgendered person's old
name and not their new name but
regardless you're now suspended from
twitter for sharing a screenshot tell us
what's going on
yes jordan peterson tweeted about ellen
page ellen page was i guess is the
correct word i mean it's all so stupid
was the actress who we all knew from
x-men x-men that's kind of funny right
uh and she then decided to transition to
be a male she's not biologically male
but she is a trans male i suppose jordan
peterson commented on that and then got
suspended all i did was share the
screenshot of that and say hey twitter's
getting out of control with these
suspensions now i've been suspended for
that and uh look this is the world that
we live in right now these tech
platforms in many ways have superseded
our first amendment rights it's not that
i can't walk outside my house and say
what i want but twitter and facebook and
youtube they are the ubiquitous tools
that we all have on this little devilish
device that's in our pocket that allow
us to communicate with the world and
they have decided that whatever they
decide on any given moment as you just
said john nobody knew what dead naming
was before i i have no problem with
trans people as an adult if you wish to
do whatever you want with your body live
with whoever you want live as whoever
you want wear whatever you want i don't
really care about any of that stuff but
i won't bend reality and the use of
words and the truth to your subjective
feelings on any given day so look
twitter has said if i delete the tweet i
can be back on i'm not sure what i'm
going to do jordan peterson says he's
not getting back on the debate that i'm
sort of having internally is hey do you
do you go into the rat's nest and fight
which would be going back on twitter or
do you say hey you know what that thing
is trash that thing is is a burning
cesspool i'm going to go off and build
new things which as you know john that
that is what i like to do i started
local for this very reason we we joined
forces with rumble and maybe that's
really the way to go but you know you
cannot tell me that the woman who played
a female character in x-men
uh ellen page that i have to refer to
her as elliot page now or i'm not
allowed to be in uh you know in polite
society it's like this term we have to
use sometimes it's a very awkward
phrasing but then vice presidential
candidate it's it's like that you know
i'm constantly researching this and i
always find myself why am i spending 25
minutes of my day trying to make sure i
use allosexual and not asexual because
asexual is now privileged because it's
normal or whatever it just you know
we're going to go down this and this is
all we're going to do is research
pronouns and dead naming and they want
and that's what they want us to do they
want us distracted by this stuff dave so
we don't focus on the basics going
forward
going forward when i do the uh the john
bachman program and i love doing the
show i would like under my name i would
like it to say decepticon leader okay
reuben you do that whatever you want
dave that's the world we live in
nowadays we'll put it on your
participation trophy as well yes of
course great to see you as always and
make sure you catch dave if you can down
in miami on july 14th great stuff in the
book and the stand-up is
choice as well dave great to see you
thanks john if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell